Dr. Zakir, the first
question I'd like to pose to you
is
are there any other fasts other than the
obligatory fasts in Islam?
Alhamdulillah. Wa salat wa salam ala
rasul Allah wa ala alihi wa sahbihi
ajma'in. Amma ba'd. A'uzubillah min
ash-shaytan ir-rajeem. Bismillah
ir-rahman ir-rahim. Rabbi shrahli sadri
wa yassirli amri wahlul uqdatan min
lisani yafqahu qawli.
In Islam
the deeds and the actions
they're divided into two types. One is
the obligatory, known as the fard,
and the other is the voluntary,
that is known as optional.
Same thing in fast also, we have the
obligatory fast, known as the fard fast,
and the voluntary fast, known as
tatawwu.
Allah subhana wa ta'ala has made certain
deeds and actions fard for all the
Muslims. This is the minimum requirement
for every Muslim to fulfill, for every
believer to complete.
And actually to it
by the grace of Allah subhana wa ta'ala,
he has kept things which are voluntary,
so that we get more thawāb, we get more
blessings, and it can even compensate
and repair and fulfill some of
the obligatory things they have missed
or some mistakes we do. So,
alhamdulillah, it is the grace of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala, the mercy of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala, that he has made
things which are voluntary, which give
more chance to compensate for things
they have missed, and more chances to go
to jannah. So, similarly, in the pillar
of fasting, we have the obligatory fast,
as well as the voluntary fast, known as
tatawwu.
Okay, thank you. Well, in that case,
could you actually highlight or mention
what are the
um voluntary fasts as recommended by the
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam?
As far as voluntary fasts are concerned,
besides
the days which are fard to fast,
that's the month of Ramadan,
and those days which are prohibited to
fast,
a Muslim can fast on any other day in
the full year.
But, there are certain days which the
Prophet has recommended
where a Muslim, if he fasts, it is much
more preferable, and he'll get more
thawāb.
First is fasting in the month of
Muharram, especially Ashura.
Number two is
fasting on the day of Arafah.
Number three is fasting during the first
10 days of the month of Dhul-Hijjah.
Number four
fasting
in the month of Shawwal.
Number five is fasting in the month of
Sha'ban.
Number six is fasting
during the forbidden months.
Ashhurul Hurum,
the forbidden months.
Number seven is
fasting on the ayyamul bid,
that's three days in the month, 13th,
14th, and 15th
of every month.
Number eight is
fasting on Mondays and Thursdays.
And number nine is fasting on alternate
days of the year.
So, these
are the nine types of fast which the
Prophet had
especially recommended.